حرب البحر الاسود تتوسع وتاخذ ابعد حرب
استنزاف جديده مره اخرى تلجا القوات
الاوكرانيه الى مسيرات بحريه لضرب اهداف
روسيه بالقرب من جسر كيرش الذي يربط روسيا
بشبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها عام 2014
استهدفت مسيره اوكرانيه ناقده نفط روسيه
مصادر في امن الدوله وسلاح الجو الاوكراني
قالت ان الناقله كانت تحمل وقودا للقوات
الروسيه واوضحت ان المسيره التي استهدفت
الناقله الروسيه كانت تحمل 450 كلغ من
المتفجرات اعترفت الوكاله الفيدراليه
الروسيه للنقل البحري بان الناقله الروسيه
تعرضت للهجوم الذي تسبب في ثقب بغرفه
المحركات على جانب الناقله الايمن
ما يزيد من خطوره الهجوم انه وقع بالقرب
من جسر كرش وتسبب في توقف الحركه على
الجسر ثلاث ساعات توعدت روسيا بالرد على
الهجوم الذي وصفته بالارهابي وقال
ديمتريديف الرئيس السابق ونائب مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي ان بلاده ستنفذ مزيدا من
الهجمات على الموانئ الاوكرانيه والتي
ستنهي اي امر في احياء اتفاق الحبوب حسب
تعبيره وتوعد اوكرانيا بكارثه بيئيه لم
يحدد معالمها في هذه الحرب البحريه تبقى
شبه جزيره القرم الهدف الابرز للقوات
الاوكرانيه حاكم التي يوجد بها مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي قال انه تم رصد مسيره
بحريه واتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه لتدميرها
قبل هذه الهجمات بساعات قادت القوات
الاوكرانيه انها استهدفت سفينه حربيه
روسيه في ميناء
جنوبي روسيا وتحدثت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عن رصد مسيرتين اوكرانيتين متجهتين الى
الميناء اعتبرت الاوكرانيه الهجوم على
الميناء في الجنوب الروسي رساله الى موسكو
مفادها ان الموانئ الروسيه ليست في مامن
بل ان وكاله الملاحه الاوكرانيه وجه
التحذيرا لسته موانئ قاعده انها تعتبرها
منطقه مخاطر حربيه تاتي هذه التحركات
الاوكرانيه بعد الضربات التي طالت موانع
اوكرانيه اثر انسحاب روسيا من اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب تعدت الهجمات الروسيه موانئ البحر
الاسود ووصلت الى الموانئ النهريه
الاوكرانيه على نهر الدانوب ويبدو ان
كيايف تحاول استخدام المسيرات وسيله للردع
ولتحقيق نوع من التوازن العسكري في البحر
الاسود